les femmes à jouer celle là
à vous mademoiselle chutait
au nom coûteux mais écoutez mademoiselle
futé mais je voulais déjà expliqué 100
fois la boule doit se tenir comme ceci
sous la paume de la main afin de mieux
contrôler la course comme ça la coûteuse
par quick et quant à françois palais
nommé n'avait pas lorsque vous me
demandez très difficile alors parler
moins vite ménagement très bien
mademoiselle futé je veux parler
gentiment alors vous prenez la boule
comme ceux ci la vous plier sur les
jambes vous évaluez liés à la distance
qui vous sépare du cochonnet et vous
lancez votre boule comme ceci voilà à
vous gérer mais essayez de faire aimer
la manne bras vous allez allez
je sens que ça va très très bien
mais non c'était paris
machar a donné dans un jeu de pétanque
vous êtes une catastrophe ambulante
françois voulez vous dire à ce monsieur
je ne lui parle plus il reprend donc un
moment notre entraîneur
puis voilà nous allons pouvoir nous
allons pouvoir y aller ensemble
en pleine forme je suis sûr que nous
allons gagner le concours vous avez pas
mais attention parce que
ça n'a pas d'importance tu sais j'ai
demandé à tous les enfants de crier
allez casini à l'ecstasy ça va casser le
moral de l'adversaire
à
légaliser le dr a su enfin on veut jouer
à la pétanque tranquillement mais ce
n'est rien ce n'est qu'un début vous
verrez pendant le concours ce sera
encore plus forts non mon cher ami je ne
verrai pas car je le parti veut pas
cette manifestation quand quelqu un qu
est ce que ça vous me faites pas le
concours exactement il est trop nul il a
peur d'être ridicule
mais en face je ne comprends pas tous
les habitants de l'île ont accepté de
faire ce concours je ne vois pas
pourquoi vous vous seriez le seul à ne
pas faire nous sommes dans une île libre
que je sache non oui mais ça n'a rien à
voir tout le monde fait le concours de
pétanque vous devez le faire également
que je vois casimir mais je ne suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec toi ni avec
vous non plus d'ailleurs monsieur de
snob
ça y est voilà la leçon de morale âme
mais n'ont quasi mieux ne s'agit pas
d'une leçon de morale pas du tout mais
si je te veux dire que c'est que ce
n'est pas très très sympathique qu'en
refusant de faire le championnat de
pétanque avec nous chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'il veut ici à je retiens que
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut
et ces voix là et moi j'en retiens que
vous n'êtes pas casser un parti qui ont
cessé de vous disputer il est là
alors bonne chance à tous à tout à
l'heure c'est énorme si tu ce nom
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
où
oui oui
morales elle est belle elle est superbe
aux bravo julie vous l'avez bien mûri et
aussi surtout grâce à quasi nue ça on
peut dire que casimir fait une partie de
pétanque extraordinaire ça je vous dire
que vous aviez un excellent partenaire
mais la victoire d'une équipe est celle
de tous ses membres merci mademoiselle
excité je vais la mettre en valeur dans
mon 4 julie n'oublie pas l'heure du
goûter tout le monde vote il y est
d'accord
les enfants vous avez vu casimir est moi
nous venons gagner le grand concours de
pétanque
mes très chers amis je viens me joindre
à vous afin d'aller au goûter comme ça
casimir ne pourra pas dire que je ne
fais pas comme tout le monde mais à pro
pour casimir de nous rejoindre ici pour
que nous allions tous ensemble goûter
tiens donc quasiment ne ferait donc pas
comme tout le monde monsieur d'histoire
je vous interdit de dire du mal de
casimir
ailleurs voici qu'arrive cuisine vieux
mais dépêche toi et pêche tout en béton
pourquoi on le goûte et voyons mais
qu'est goûter mais le goûter organisé
pour le concours de pétanque où tout le
monde doit aller on va peut-être tout le
monde mais pas moi c'est gazinière de
nous avait dit mademoiselle futur comme
ceux du snap m'a expliqué qu'il ne
voulait pas faire comme tout le monde
françois m'a fait comprendre qu'il avait
parfaitement le droit de faire ce qui
lui plaisait c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai
dit ça casimir mai mais ici c'est
différent et si du n'assiste pas au but
et ce sera triste pour nous de toute
façon que je sois là ou pas votre goûter
sera prise mais y'a un gros gâteau à la
meringue fourrées au chocolat et aux
pralines et bien non je lis il n'y a
plus de gap aux
plus de gâteaux ont fait ce tutoiement
tic à nourrir aux miracles je m'explique
comme françois m'a fait comprendre qu'on
n'avait pas fait le droit de ne pas
faire comme tout le monde au lieu de
faire comme tout le monde et d'attendre
je suis allé manger le goûter avant
casini
[Musique]